évidemment on s'est affolé un peu vite
mais c'est normal on a une affaire comme
ça les médias s'y mettent tout le monde
est inquiet on ne sait pas ce que c'est
on ne sait pas d'où ça vient donc il y a
une espèce d'emballement qui s'est
produit mais moi je veux dire que j'ai
jamais été très impressionné par cette
affaire-là j'étais beaucoup plus
impressionné comme l'a rappelé Patrick
Cohen à l'instant par l'ampleur des
destructions qui ont été infligées par
les Russes à la population
ukrainienne les Russes selon une formule
célèbre ne font la guerre actuellement
cociville c'est absolument et là il y
avait un phénomène et je crois que au
bout du compte je crois que Monsieur
j'ai cru comprendre que le président
Biden avait une formule à ses heureuse
il avait dit
au bout du compte c'est quand même une
responsabilité parce que c'est c'est
effectivement une contre c'est une balle
perdue si je comprends bien ils ont
envoyé un missile qui a dû qui s'était
garé etc dans une stratégie de défense
donc la responsabilité
alors moi je n'ai jamais cru qui aurait
un risque d'emballement je pense que si
ça avait été d'origine russe serait sans
doute été une bavure un échec etc
peut-être que ça aurait pu entraîner une
réaction proportionnée immédiate mais je
ne pense pas qu'on soit du tout dans une
situation comparable à celle que vous
avez évoqué
là on avait vraiment une volonté très
très délibérée d'Hitler et de Staline
d'ailleurs
les mécanismes d'alliance mettent en
place on a vu
Varsovie beaucoup de retenue les
Polonais qu'on à qui on n'a pas
l'habitude de reconnaître une réputation
de modération énorme ont été parfaits
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont aussitôt demandé
non pas la mise en oeuvre de l'article 5
l'article l'article 4 qui était
simplement la réunion du conseil de
l'OTAN pour examiner la situation et les
Américains qui qui sont ceux qui
détiennent l'information ont eu
l'habiliter à mon avis de donner
l'information au Polonais si bien que ce
sont les Polonais eux-mêmes qui ont été
amenés à dire que c'était pas les Russes
là on voit quand même quelque chose qui
me frappe depuis le début de cette
affaire depuis 24 février c'est
l'extraordinaire maîtrise des Américains
de toute la gestion de ce conflit du
sang-froid à la fois de la rigueur de la
modération de de l'opportunité etc c'est
sans doute le effectivement le patron de
la CIA qui est un homme très remarquable
qui qui orchestre tout ça de façon assez
magistrale ça contraste tellement avec
les improvisations complètement
fantasmes du président Trump dans la
période antérieure
et plus la guerre dure plus ce genre
d'incident risque de se généraliser
Jean-Luc Bolland moi je crois que ce qui
est très grave c'est la décision que les
je suis convaincu depuis longtemps que
les Russes considèrent que ce qu'ils ont
fait jusqu'à présent à l'Ukraine c'est
une guerre extrêmement douce
alors c'est pas nos critères mais ce
sont les leurs comparé à ce qu'ils ont
fait à grossiste qu'ils ont fait en
Syrie et donc ils sont décidés à
infliger à la population
ukrainienne des des As des dommages
absolument énormes et à pourrir
véritablement la vie quotidienne de tous
les ukrainiens et il me semble de ce
point de vue là que le on parle le
reconstruction mais je crois que la
véritable le véritable enjeu pour nous
au-delà de l'aide militaire il faut
continuer à donner des armes et même
sans doute renforcer l'aide en matière
de missile mais au-delà de ça il faut
véritablement faire quelque chose qui
s'apparente un peu à ce qui a été tout
est différent bien sûr à ce qui a été le
point aérien sur Berlin en 1948
c'est-à-dire une aide je crois que les
puissances occidentales doivent vraiment
orchestrer une aide systématique en
direction de l'Ukraine pour permettre
ces millions de gens de vivre pendant
l'hiver sans crever de faim sans crever
de froid en pouvant ça c'est un immense
effort que nous devons entreprendre la
guerre a changé de nature et l'action
civile doit sera aussi importante que
l'action militaire dans les mois qui
viennent vous l'avez rappelé tous les
deux l'Ukraine était particulièrement
touchée hier ce qui a fait réagir en ces
termes le Président vous le délir
zelandskium
[Musique]
domicile c'est aussi un avertissement
justement membre du G20 comme le pense
le président ukrainien peut-être
peut-être mais je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec l'analyse de Patrick Cohen
sur le fait que on avait une grande
interrogation il y a quelques mois
notamment au printemps savoir on avait
l'Ouest l'est et le reste le reste
c'était la Chine c'était l'un c'était
l'Afrique c'était le Brésil et on avait
le sentiment et les diplomates français
avaient sentiments aussi que le reste
nous échappait que le reste au bout du
compte disait toutes ces affaires
européennes c'est des affaires de
puissance coloniale ça ne nous regarde
pas vous ne nous attirez pas dans cette
ce conflit entre l'Ukraine et la Russie
et on a vraiment le sentiment que depuis
deux trois mois les choses ont
profondément changé que un certain
nombre de puissance est d'abord la Chine
mesure les conséquences collatérales
énormes sur l'ordre économique sur
l'ordre mondial sur la lutte climatique
va sur un ensemble d'en de la poursuite
de ce conflit et donc là on a
effectivement un isolement assez grand
de la part des Russes par l'ensemble de
la communauté c'est ça que signifie
effectivement le G20 c'est un élément
vraiment nouveau par rapport à la
situation il y a quelques mois ce que
vous dites c'est exactement ce qu'a
voulu souligner Emmanuel Macron avec son
discours pour clore pour clore le G20 en
tout cas c'est ce que dit le communiqué
comment c'est que la plupart des membres
du G20 on fermement condamné la guerre
en Ukraine mais pas un sommet du G20 qui
décide de la paix ou qui permet
d'arrêter une guerre nos débats sur la
base d'ailleurs de propositions que nous
avions faites montrent qu'il existe un
espace de convergence y compris avec les
grands émergents comme la Chine et
l'Inde
pour pousser la Russie à la désescalade
même si le président Poutine n'était pas
venu le message que lui envoie les plus
grandes puissances économiques du monde
réunies à Bali et très clair la grande
majorité des membres du G20 condamne
explicitement la guerre en Ukraine le
G20 ne veut pas de la guerre
alors il faut dire un la Chine ni l'un
de encore officiellement
affiché leur rejet de la guerre en
Ukraine mais ils font pas faire ça
franchement ce sont des manœuvres
diplomatiques mais ils peuvent raisonner
Vladimir Poutine Kremlin la Chine peut
raisonner le Kremlin encore je pense
qu'elle a quand même des moyens de se
faire entendre mais effectivement ça ne
peut se faire que
clandestinement si je puis dire ça ne
sera pas vous n'aurez pas des grandes
déclarations des dirigeants chinois
disant aux Russes ça suffit mais en
revanche il a quand même tout un
ensemble de de pression ne serait-ce que
les acquisitions de de
l'hydrocarbures ou de gaz il y a quand
même tout un des moyens de pression
considérables et de l'Inde et de la
Chine surtout de la Chine Vladimir
Poutine absent du G20 quasi invisible
d'ailleurs ces derniers jours de quoi
cet effacement est-il le signe il veut
pas réagir après l'humiliation du
retrait des troupes russes à Carson ou
est-ce que c'est aussi le signe d'une
lutte de pouvoir au Kremlin
écoutez je suis vraiment je sais bien
que
vous êtes très content
quelle était la disposition des troupes
des armes nucléaires tactiques
américaines en Allemagne il avait dit
écoute tellio il fait il dit non know je
pourrais vous le dire si je ne le savais
pas moi c'est le contraire
et mais je crois quand même que la
situation de pouvoir de Poutine est
quand même très profondément modifié je
veux dire que je crois que l'ensemble
des dirigeants russes militaires civil
économie chef d'entreprise savent qu'il
a engagé le pays dans une très très
mauvaise affaire c'est quand même
l'infaillibilité pontificale du tzar a
été quand même très très profondément
mis en cause alors ça ne la dévolution
du pouvoir ont aussi c'est très
particulier c'est généralement violent
il est assez peu probable même qui est
une grande manifestation type prise de
la Bastille etc du peuple russe c'est
pas dans c'est c'est on n'a pas cet
article en magasin en Russie c'est c'est
les prises de pouvoir sont toujours par
des minorités regardez le Parti
bolchevik en 17 c'est une minorité etc
et mais quelle est exactement le le
l'analyse que font les milieux les plus
proches de Poutine il y a toujours été
même par les gens du KGB à l'époque il
avait toujours été considéré avec un peu
de méfiance ils avaient refusé de
l'engager au début parce qu'il le
trouvait un peu émotive un peu trop
nerveux comme comme Staline qui disait
de Hitler oui globalement Hitler c'est
un client sérieux mais un peu émotif et
c'est un peu la et donc ils doivent ça
doit les inquiéter mais quand même le
système de pouvoir est totalement
concentré autour de autour de Poutine et
je suis absolument alors là incapable
de dire si il est concrètement en
situation de fragilité ou pas en France
près le coup de tension d'hier soir
certaines voix s'élèvent de nouveau pour
demander des négociations comme Marine
Le Pen ce matin sur BFM qui en a
d'ailleurs profité pour sinon révéler en
tout cas exposé ce qu'est une guerre je
suis inquiète parce que je suis une mère
de famille parce que j'ai des enfants et
parce que moi la perspective d'une
guerre mondiale me fait extrêmement peur
pardon comme ça devrait l'être pour tout
le monde d'ailleurs parce que la guerre
elle n'est pas virtuelle fait des morts
elle fait des morts chez les hommes les
femmes les enfants et donc moins elle
dure mieux évidemment nous nous portons
et c'est la raison pour laquelle j'avais
sollicité qu'une grande conférence pour
la paix soit organisée par la France que
je crois que c'est le rôle historique de
la France que d'être à l'origine de
cette grande conférence pour la paix qui
pourrait réunir l'ensemble de ceux qui
évidemment sont intéressés par ce
conflit vous êtes élu modem réagissez
comment à cette proposition de grande
vous savez j'ai beaucoup de respect pour
Madame Le Pen qui est membre de la
commission des affaires étrangères et
donc tous les membres de la commission
des affaires étrangères sont très bien
seront traités avec égalité par mois au
sein de cette commission mais je ne peux
quand même pas m'empêcher de me rappeler
de rappeler que elle a été du mauvais
côté au moment de la préparation de ce
conflit qu'elle n'y a pas cru qu'elle a
marqué sa solidarité avec le président
Poutine alors que nous étions un certain
nombre à avoir du pas à dire non
l'accumulation de troupes en russe à la
frontière de l'Ukraine c'est une
promesse à coup sûr une promesse d'une
intervention moi je l'ai dit
publiquement dans certains médias alors
aujourd'hui bien sûr qui ne souscrirait
à ses propos
pacifistes de Madame Le Pen nous sommes
tous pour la nous sommes tous pour la
paix nous sommes tous pour que la France
joue un rôle important au service de la
de la paix mais de quoi s'agit-il je ne
pense pas qu'aujourd'hui les conditions
d'ailleurs le président de la République
l'avait dit lors de la conférence des
ambassadeurs il y a deux mois il avait
dit le moment n'est pas venu les Russes
comment voulez-vous que les Russes que
pourrait-il que pourrait-il accepter
l'idée c'est ça serait de quitter
l'Ukraine c'est un échec absolument
inacceptable pour Poutine tant qui tant
que la guerre dure il n'a pas perdu il
n'a pas gagné mais tant que la guerre
dure il n'a pas perdu et du côté de
Monsieur Zelinski imaginez-vous que ils
disent bah écoutez on a bien on a bien
réfléchi on va en arrêter là on va
laisser le don de base tout ce qui est à
gauche du Nieppe on va laisser au et la
Crimée on va laisser russe il disparaît
immédiatement de la scène politique moi
j'étais en Ukraine avec madame la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
madame brune Puvis il y a quelques
semaines on voit immensité de l'effort
de la mobilisation des deuils des
sacrifices consentis par les par les
ukrainiens et c'est pas on va pas leur
dire maintenant c'est fini on recommence
comme avant et tout vos sacrifices
servent à rien donc pour l'instant la
situation est véritablement et
véritablement bloqué on va voir comment
évolue la situation militaire je ne suis
pas rassuré je crois que les Russes
n'ont pas dit leur dernier mot le
général en chef qui a russe
qui a organisé le départ de personnes de
façon assez intelligente d'ailleurs bien
que ce soit une humiliation très grande
n'a pas dit son dernier mot il va
essayer de reprendre l'initiative ça va
pas être facile pour lui parce que je
crois que les Russes sont très
démoralisés très désorganisés enfin ils
vont ils ont des moyens de destruction
considérables sur la population
ukrainienne donc je crois que la
véritable ce que devrait dire Madame Le
Pen c'est ce que nous disons nous pour
l'instant temps l'urgence c'est d'aider
les Ukrainiens de les aider
militairement à résister notamment en
leur donnant des armes antimissiles qui
leur permettent de les protéger et en
les en aidant fondamentalement la
population
ukrainienne a passé l'hiver c'est
d'abord la solidarité tout en veillant
ce que nous faisons les uns et les
autres dans les différents pays de
l'Alliance occidentale tout en veillant
à ce que la guerre soit contenue dans
des limites précises et qu'elles ne
déborde pas sur un plan mondial donc
c'est ça c'est ça notre devoir si vous
voulez le reste ça sera donné de
surcroît si il se passe quelque chose si
par exemple il y a des modifications de
pouvoir à Moscou ce serait évidemment
quelque chose sur lequel on devrait
immédiatement prendre appui c'est
peut-être une des solutions pour les
Russes de dire on met on met quelqu'un
d'autre et ce quelqu'un d'autre pourrait
être un interlocuteur et pourra nous
permettre
de sauver l'honneur des Russes la honte
étant assumée si je puis dire par
Poutine
dans une situation un peu donc il y a
peut-être des scénarios comme ça mais
bon d'autres sujets à vous soumettre le
volant parce que vous l'avez reçu
à Kiev qui a qui était qui nous a reçu
l'autre jour qui était formidable et ce
livre est formidable parce que c'est la
guerre au jour le jour vous l'avez reçu
je crois monsieur la semaine dernière
avoir des diplomates comme ça vraiment
le pays doit en être fier et il va
mettre intelligent sur la brèche
constamment attentif à la défense de nos
concitoyens à la solidarité que nos
alliés moi je suis fier d'avoir des des
représentants du du corps diplomatique
de cette qualité merci beaucoup
Jean-Yves